so great to be here in New Haven on the
on a rainy
and I don't get up here that often but I
have a lot of friends and number them
are in the audience today that have
become friends we started out as
colleagues and we're actually friends
now so that's always good and as Robert
said I am going to talk about my percept
my view of the data that supports the
notion that the drug abuse treatment is
an HIV prevention intervention and some
of the limitations of how that's played
out in the world today and some thoughts
on future directions and future research
so that's needed so the basic points I
want to make is I first want to set the
stage epidemiologically and just remind
everyone of what the what we know about
the epidemic of HIV that's driven by
injection drug use you'll be most of the
data is focused on injection drug use
even though probably most of the
infections are related to non injection
drug use and drug abuse I won't talk
much specifically about hepatitis C but
I want everyone to be thinking in terms
of HIV / hepatitis C these are
infections that are transmitted through
the same behavioral mechanisms hepatitis
E is transmitted left through sexual
transmission than HIV but definitely is
easily spread through the use of
contaminated injection equipment so I
want to make sure that's a prominent
theme in this talk as well the the data
that i'll present really is going to be
a summary of data that comes primarily
from methadone treatment i'll present
this as a proof of concept basically
that
effective drug treatments can reduce HIV
infection and to a certain extent
hepatitis C infection but I don't want
us to restrict our thinking to methadone
treatment even though that's where the
past 20 years worth of data has
primarily been in focus we still despite
lots of evidence I think can say that we
have minimal treatment coverage in the
United States but more prominently in
the rest of the world we just don't have
enough access to treatment to meet the
demand or the and certainly not the need
and so we have to think about ways to
take the knowledge that we've gained and
expand options for people to receive
treatments who are substance abuse and
I'll talk a little bit about that and
finally making the point that there will
be much more effective in our efforts if
we view drug treatment not as sufficient
but as necessary component of a public
health model that includes a number of
fact in a number of interventions in
programs that we know reduce the spread
of HIV infection among drug users so
those are five points I have about 40
slides to make five points so just bear
with me and basically most of you are
probably familiar with the basic
epidemiology of AIDS and HIV infection
related to injection drug use probably
about 33 million people currently
infected with HIV approximately 10
million infections
can be or have been attributed to
injection drug use outside of
sub-saharan Africa we project that about
a third of all new infections or related
to injection drug use even though we're
changing our perception of Africa
there's a lot more recognition now of
the prevalence of drug use and its role
in the spread of HIV and including
injection drug use but perhaps most
importantly we don't have many good
estimates of the major role of alcohol
and non injection drugs in the global
epidemic and wherever we look we find
pretty substantial roles for for these
substances in the transmission of HIV
infection I just want to make that point
a little more clear with some data from
the Explorer project which followed
about 4,000 non injecting men who have
sex with men it tested an intervention
that proved not to be efficacious it was
about a 12 session intervention using
counseling strategies with with the men
to reduce HIV risk behaviors when the
study was finished however there were
about 300 HIV infections in this group
of four thousand individuals and when it
would and when analyses were done to
predict or to look at the predictors of
HIV infection there were the the
strongest predictors were actually
substance use related so these are
sexual transmissions not the injection
related transmissions the hazard ratio
of 1.87 for heavy alcohol use 1.9 34 and
fed
in use that accounted for 67 infections
among the 500 and the 27 people who
reported using amphetamines and for
those who reported using alcohol or
drugs prior to sexual activity a hazard
ratio of 1.57 is I'm using this data
because it's the largest study of non
injection drug users and predictors of
HIV infection that we have so far and I
think it reminds all of us that we need
to pay much more attention to developing
effective treatments for non injection
drug use particularly in high-risk
populations like men who have sex with
with men now historically prevention
strategies for drug use in populations
have included the first education HIV
counseling and testing increased access
to sterile injection resources and
condoms drug treatment and more recently
HIV treatment or considered effective
strategies for reducing risk behaviors
and infections among drug using
populations I'm going to be talking
primarily about the drug treatment but
I'm going to return to this point at the
end and saying that all of these
strategies need to be present if we're
talking about protecting communities
from the spread of HIV infection it's
also important for you to understand my
view or at least my understanding of
addiction as we start this discussion
addiction is a medical condition it's a
treatable but a chronic medical
condition there are important biological
components that some of our medications
that we've developed can help too
dress there are behavioral components
that need equal attention in in
treatment as well and i would say that
we've kind of minimize the importance of
these behavioral interventions
particularly drug-related counseling in
conjunction with the use of with of
medications and we're not really talking
about cures for addiction we talk about
effective management like other chronic
medical conditions there is a
requirement for ongoing interaction with
health professionals now there are a
number of factors that influence how we
think about the drug treatment in our
ability in the ability of drug treatment
to actually have an impact on the
epidemic some of these factors include
the prevalence of of drug use in a
particular area that's going to have an
impact on how we design and deliver
treatments the mode of administration
the types of drugs in the drug company
combinations that are being used in by
individuals in communities color kering
infections and political forces are all
going to have an impact on the kind of
drug treatments that are not only
possible but but important to be able to
deliver the CDC estimates we have about
a hundred thousand adults in the United
States this was in 2007 that are living
with HIV or excuse me living with AIDS
diagnosis this is just a map like Maps I
think it reminds us that first of all
the epidemic is not randomly distributed
geographically and we have
tremendous variation in prevalence rates
and risk of infection as well now this
is related to injection drug use and
obviously the East Coast and
particularly the Northeast is more
heavily impacted by by injection drug
use and again that's going to have an
impact on the kind of treatment systems
in treatment approaches that are are
developed also the mixture of drugs this
is the WA chose estimates of the types
of drugs that are being used and are
leading people into treatment around the
world these pie charts just show a
distribution of the number of people
entering treatment in their primary drug
of abuse the green represents cocaine
and the gray area stimulants the the
brownish color is the opiates heroin
primarily and the yellow is marijuana
they as you can see I mean in the United
States even though stimulants might be
the predominant reason for entering
treatment there is a variety of drugs
available and being used and that's
increasingly the pattern that that we're
seeing but despite the fact that the
addiction is a medical problem the these
variations require different strategies
for for treatment and as does the motive
administration this just is an estimate
of the prevalence of injection drug use
globally with the darker shaded areas
higher prevalence as you can see in no
country is the estimate much higher than
1% despite that factor we have enough
countries where the majority of HIV
infections are attributable to injection
drug use so this is I'm sure you know
for those of your all or most of you are
in students in public health and
probably have already learned this but
it seems to me that this data clearly
makes the point that when we neglect the
health of even a small slice of the
population it can have huge impacts on
the overall health of the overall public
health and the health of communities
I've been working more recently in Asia
in China and Indonesia where the
epidemics are still strongly being
driven by injection drug use in China
it's restricted to certain prob
provinces in Indonesia it seems to be
still the primary risk group that's
driving the epidemic is in injection
drug use Malaysia is an Vietnam have
similar patterns as well so there are
still regions of the world where
injection drug use is the predominant
motive of transmission we're doing a
study in Jakarta right now where we're
looking at the impact of adding
counseling to people coming into
methadone treatment programs and in the
program already seventy percent of the
patients are infected with HIV so these
are patients in methadone treatment who
are already infected with with HIV and
seventy percent of the patients who have
HIV infection are also infected with
tuberculosis so there are huge treatment
issues and and unique challenges in the
these regions of the world this is data
from except for the Philadelphia bar
charts here this is data from a
relatively small study but it's
interesting because they introduced this
was a wh 0 project that introduced the
methadone treatment or buprenorphine
treatment in China Indonesia Thailand
Iran lithuania and poland the red bars
represent the prevalence of the of HIV
infection of people coming into the the
treatment programs again this is China
Indonesia Thailand Iran Lithuania sorry
you can't read the bottom there Poland
and this is Philadelphia by the way but
that was to make another point for
another talk but the the green charts
represent hepatitis C and so an obvious
finding and you know an important point
is that in the same communities where we
see even low prevalence of HIV infection
in the same populations we see almost
universally very high prevalence of
hepatitis C and again this is a virus
that that we have not yet come to grips
with in terms of effective Prevention's
we're developing many more effective
treatments now looks like we're going to
have protease inhibitors and similar
kinds of treatment approaches for
hepatitis C but right now there's not
much work being done to prepare for the
treatment of drug users with these new
medications so I think there's a real
research and the treatment opportunity
with the new medications for hepatitis C
I mentioned earlier the politics has
always has an impact on not only the
availability of drugs the distribution
of drugs but it also has an impact on
what treatments are are acceptable and
what approaches are are going to get the
the most public support this is a border
crossing between Vietnam and Laos and
basically it's a sign that you can find
on in in some form at almost every
border crossing in the world which says
if you're caught with drugs they'll be
severe consequences some countries it's
more severe than other countries but
there are still consequences and it's
generally not a good idea to to get
caught with drugs but the you know the
the strategy that is universal and still
receives the most funding for to address
the drug problem in the world our
criminal justice approaches probably the
next most common is detoxification
approaches in one form or another this
is from the largest the detoxification
center in China it's in Wuhan China this
was we were doing a study ten years ago
in Wuhan and we were offered the 1000
residents of the the detoxification
center as subjects in those future
studies but China has made some amazing
progress in the development of treatment
programs and I don't want that to be the
last word that I say about the China in
fact I have some slides later on to to
talk about that but the point I want to
make is that
globally governments have invested very
heavily in detoxification approaches
that just don't work their time limited
they basically remove people from the
community they detoxify them for sure
but there's no treatment there's no
evidence that this approach has
sustained treatment when people leave
these programs relapse rates from
detoxification alone are over ninety
percent within three months of the end
of the treatment within the I'm going to
just show you very briefly some data
that's almost 20 years old now it gets
shown a lot by a lot of people and I'm
it's it's it's my data so that's why I'm
showing it and it was but I think one of
the reasons it actually gets presented
often is because it's one of the few
prospective studies we have on on drug
users and HIV infection who are both the
in methadone treatment these bars here
show the prevalence rates of HIV
infection in Philadelphia among 255 drug
users half of them were in methadone
treatment and enrolled and followed for
six years and the infection rates went
from 13 to 21 percent and for those who
were recruited from the same
neighborhood and we're out of treatment
and followed for the same amount of time
we had by the way over an 80% retention
rate for this whole period although
forty percent of the participants died
during the course of the study
the prevalence rates were higher at
baseline and showed a much higher rate
of new infections so people at night i
love this slot you know and even this
summer you know was shown in in making
the point that the drug treatment
prevents HIV infection the story's a lot
more complicated than that but we've
actually made a very good sales pitch
using this data and we've convinced lots
of people that methadone treatment is
HIV infection and it's I think had a
positive effect of spreading the the
notion of drug treatment as an HIV
prevention intervention we've not been
as successful at making the point that
addiction treatment is HIV prevention
and and so that's resulted in I think a
simplistic view of of HIV prevention by
distributing by establishing systems
that are good at distributing
medications particularly methadone again
I'll talk more about that in a minute we
also have some data from other studies
of course other than the study that I
did or was involved in and but not much
data on hepatitis B prevention or
hepatitis C prevention that actually
measured these the incidence of these
infections and again what we see is this
is a study that was done in Seattle by
Hannah Theed and Holly Hagan looking at
people who entered treatment looking at
them 12 months later and the red bars
represent the people who left treatment
and
those individuals have the highest
incidence rate for hepatitis B and
hepatitis C for the people who were in
tremont part of the time we see a
somewhat lower rate and the lowest rates
of infections for both hepatitis B and
hepatitis C were among people who were
in methadone treatment and stayed in
treatment for the 12 months so we have
lots of data now collected over the past
25 years that suggests first of all that
effective treatments a recognized
addiction as a chronic disease they use
pharmacologic interventions as well as
counseling interventions and are
accessible acceptable and affordable so
how does how you know what is the
mechanism of action of treatment how
does treatment prevent people from
getting infected I think it's actually a
rather simple model when drug treatments
are effective people reduce the
frequency of drug use from the lower
frequency of drug use results in fewer
drug-related risk behaviors and fewer
infections we also importantly have data
now a growing amount of data to show
that the people in drug treatment
programs have increased access to HIV
care if they're already infected with
HIV as well as the primary health care
and that those who are in treatment NHO
end in HIV care have greater adherence
to their their HIV medications and all
of these things contribute to reductions
in the transmission of HIV
importantly there was a study done
recently and I say importantly because
it it's not the simply a matter of
entering a treatment program the
treatment has to be effective in
reducing drug use and whoa what this
study which was done in in France it
looked at the drug users who are in both
the buprenorphine treatment and
methadone maintenance treatment and
these bars here are people who were in
treatment and we're not continuing to
inject and their adherence rates were
equivalent to those who are abstinence
or people who were not never used used
drugs so being in treatment it is
important but it's not as important as
stopping your use of drugs and there are
as many of you know many people who were
in treatment programs but continue to
use drugs it's really the drug use that
interferes with these these other
behaviors those who were in
buprenorphine treatment and methadone
treatment and who continued to inject
were twice as likely to be non-adherent
to their medication and much more
similar to those who were who were drug
dependent but not in treatment at all
and continue to inject so it's not a
matter of just entering treatment that
reduces risk or improves adherence it's
actually responding to the treatment so
basically we have these data from the
past 25 years that are all very positive
findings and the question that I think
is important for us to consider at this
point in the epidemic is have they had
an impact have these data had an impact
and i would say that we can say yeah
been there are limited places are there
examples in the world where we can show
that these data have propelled the
expansion primarily a methadone
treatment in these places I would say
also that as I mentioned earlier that
most of these treatments are promoted as
harm reduction strategies where the goal
is to get people on methadone and
distribute and and keep them on
methadone but there's very little
attention paid to the addiction
treatment which requires some attention
to counseling and the individuals
motivation and intentions to stop using
drugs I would say it's had little effect
on reducing on interventions designed to
reduce non injection drug use and and
its relationship to HIV risk behaviors
as well as a stimulant use we still
don't have much if much in the way of
effective treatments for for stimulants
and we don't have much emphasis on
reducing risk for hepatitis C or
expanding treatments for hepatitis C
probably the best example of where this
date has had an impact is China they've
gone from zero methadone programs in
2004 to over 600 methadone clinics today
this is a couple years old and I believe
there are about 200,000 patients on
methadone treatment it's the largest the
treatment system really in the the
history of the world and it's been
developed most rapidly and I think it's
really a monumental achievement and one
that that China should be very proud of
that we
all be proud of unfortunately the
treatment system as I mentioned has not
been focused in my opinion sufficiently
enough on on a treating addiction but on
distributing methadone but it's you know
it's new and there's there are a number
of people in China that that are
interested in improving and improving
the efficacy of methadone treatment
night is involved i'll talk about a
study that we're currently doing with
suboxone in china richard shadon felled
in merrick sworsky are doing a study now
in wuhan china in the methadone
treatment trying to evaluate the impact
of of the counseling program there so
there are they're great developments
there are questions research questions
that we can not ask in other places
because of the the scale of the program
that we see in china in the stage of
development and we're starting to see
some of the same same patterns of
findings in terms of the impact and
again this was done in sichuan china by
han xue quan and it shows the rate of
needle sharing among people who among
injectors who have no history of
methadone treatment compared to those
with a past history and those who are
currently in treatment and again we're
seeing the obviously the same pattern of
risk behaviors and so one of the
important things that we're able to do
with this kind of data is when we set it
the next to data from other settings
around the world we can start developing
I think models for our expected rate of
Risk Reduction for people involved in
if in methadone treatment even though
the the rate of needle sharing may vary
from these places the the impact of the
treatment may actually be quite similar
there's obviously a clear need for more
treatment options this is from a recent
article by Mathers and the the wh 0
group and it just you know the red the
red here represents countries that don't
have any medication assisted treatment
for opiate dependence and it's obviously
a significant issue for Russia which it
has a huge epidemic among opiate
injectors and no policy in policies that
prohibit the use of methadone or
suboxone or other agonist treatments the
other shades represent various just the
presence of the clinics that the treat
using methadone and suboxone or both the
actual level of coverage is quite
variable as you can imagine Australia
Europe United States Canada tend to have
among the higher rates globally but the
rest of the world has rates that are
less than well if they have treatment at
all is less than two or three percent of
the injectors have access to these
treatments that we know can be effective
so there's just a huge scale up that's
required if we're going to provide
adequate coverage and my own opinion is
that we can only do so much with
suboxone and with methadone and we have
to
necessarily think of new strategies new
treatment approaches and new mechanisms
for delivering treatments that we know
are effective so one of the more recent
although it's now it's almost 10 years
since its approval was approved in 2002
but buprenorphine locks on suboxone
there are people in the room here who
have devoted their careers to to
studying the impact and models for
delivery of this David and Rick but it
actually is has some advantages over
methadone that I think make it a very
appealing medication it's a partial
agonist I won't go into the details of
that it right now but there is a reduced
risk of overdose relative to methadone
less severe withdrawal and fewer
interactions importantly with
antiretroviral medications we're
currently doing a study that I'm the
protocol chair of in Thailand in China
we have about half of our subjects
enrolled now there's 800 subjects
enrolled were targeting about 1500
subjects and we're recruiting opiate
injectors from the community and
referring them to two approaches to
suboxone treatment one is a short-term
suboxone which involves the opportunity
for to detoxification but everybody gets
one year of counseling and of course
referral to local treatment resources if
those are necessary versus a full year
of suboxone treatment everybody begins
the the study with a counselor who tells
them look we've got a year together to
work on your drug problem
let's take advantage of this time now
that's actually a unique feature of this
study a one-year treatment approach it's
you know controversial to some but it's
actually based on evidence that a
minimum of one year treatment is
necessary in order to see an impact on
infection rates in a community and also
it's based on the fact that most people
when they're offered access to methadone
treatment or suboxone treatment don't
stay in treatment for nearly this long
so I think it has some public health
relevance if we can show that these
treatments have sustainable impact and
we'll be following folks for two years
so a year after treatment wilt will be
following individuals now it's powered
based upon incidence of HIV infection
that's a requirement for the HIV
prevention trials Network we're not
seeing enough infections to answer the
primary study question at this point so
we're already gearing up for answering
our secondary questions which will take
a look at continued injection and
reductions in in risky behaviors but
again this is when I said earlier that
we need to start developing and testing
new models of treatment this is the kind
of thinking that I think well certainly
that I was referring to but I think we
need to develop new strategies and new
ways of thinking about delivering
treatment other than saying your drug
addict then you're going to need to be
in treatment for the rest of your life
although some people do need that we
have to be much more selective and much
more specific in the way we design and
deliver treatments in the Jakarta study
that I mentioned earlier we're working
with 55 methadone clinics in the city of
Jakarta and randomly assigning
individuals to methadone treatment as
usual plus the behavioral drug and risk
counseling that was developed by virtue
or ski and Richard shadon felled and
first guest tested in Malaysia but it
has some basic common elements of
cognitive behavioral approaches to to
therapy these kinds of treatments are
focused on current issues in an
individual's life short term goals are
established this is not psychotherapy
this is not talking about the origins of
a problem of drug addiction but it's
talking about how are you going to get
through tomorrow how are you going to
get back here for your medication next
week or or tomorrow so it's setting
short-term goals very practical things
that individuals without advanced
degrees can be trained on and trained to
deliver in a pretty effective way so
we're randomly assign people to
treatment as usual which allows
individuals who are having problems to
say I'd like to talk to somebody about
my problem but it does not establish a
structure to the counseling so it's
basically i would say counseling on
demand and when counseling is delivered
in these situations it's quite variable
it depends on who you ask in which
physician or which nurse ends up talking
to you as to what kind of counseling
you're going to get and quite honestly
physicians nurses and most professionals
working in the field aren't trained on
how to talk to drug users in a way that
moves them in a positive direction and
that's really what we're talking about
with the structured counseling
approaches simple ways to help people
talk to drug users in a way that
helps them understand what's going on
first of all and then helps them make
decisions that are positive decisions
most people's instinct who are not
trained in these kinds of approaches or
you know involve some form of guilt and
shame and drug users that you know
that's the one thing they have a lot of
is guilt and shame already and by
embarrassing people or making them feel
more guilty will only drive them further
away so anyway I think we've
underestimated the importance of of
counseling and as a consequence we
haven't trained people in the field well
enough on how to do productive and
positive counseling so that's the the
theory underlying this study and we'll
follow people for a year and do
behavioral and HIV tests as well this is
a study that the Merrick and Richard the
have just that I believe it's a it's in
press if it's not already published but
this is a pilot study done in wuhan now
we had a similar kind of strategy
standard methadone treatment versus
methadone treatment plus B DRC in two
clinics in wuhan and Melissa topia used
so was significantly lower at the end of
the study among the individuals who
received the methadone treatment and the
be DRC and the same this is a reduction
in risk behavior was more prominent
there was significant as well in the
BTRC group this is a zeiss mentioned
earlier based upon a counseling model
that was first used in the malaysia
study and this study compared
buprenorphine and now tracks on both to
a placebo group all groups showed
reductions in
the in risk behavior the importance of
of this study i think is also that it's
not just methadone it's not just
buprenorphine but it involves now treks
own comparisons now tracks own is an
opiate antagonist it's been around for
many years but not widely used because
patients don't want to take their
medication it blocks the effects of
opiates that you don't become dependent
on the medication so you can stop taking
it at anytime you want to so in what
we've seen in in the studies at least
that I've been most closely involved in
people genuinely want to stop their
heroin use and they generally like the
idea at one point in time that if I take
this pill I won't be able to get
dependent on heroin again I won't feel
the effects of heroin if I take it but
like I said after about a week people
start thinking boy you know a heroin you
know wasn't all bad there were some
moments of pleasure I don't have those
moments of pleasure anymore and after
two weeks they say well then maybe I
just won't take mine out wrexham today
or tomorrow and and and try some and go
back to some of those old behavior
patterns that are comfortable and
familiar and sometimes reinforce it so
in our setting in the United States
we've had almost no success except in
situations where there's a lot of social
and legal pressure on individuals we've
seen some success with guys on probation
and we've seen some success with
physicians who might lose their licenses
if they continue or relapse to to heroin
use but as a general rule is had no no
widespread applicability to the
population of heroin users and
particularly heroin users who are at
high risk of HIV infection
so and this was a study done in Russia
by George woody and the group at the
Pavlov Institute which compared
naltrexone and to placebos and
naltrexone with fluoxetine basically the
naltrexone was the active ingredient and
there was a significant the
significantly longer retention in
treatment among the individuals who got
the the naltrexone so you know I
mentioned earlier in Russia you're not
allowed to use method on so there really
are many treatment options in terms of
medication-assisted treatment so we saw
some effect there but it's also the you
know the concept of this medication is
appealing to many people and I think
lots of people have been saying for a
long time wouldn't it be nice if people
didn't have to take it every day and so
now through the development of an appt
trek zone implant and we now have
vivitrol a long-acting injection with
just one implant you can be protected
for I think this is actually for three
months oh the implant is delivered
through a syringe basically in the
abdomen and it's called pro-thaksin it's
a Russian product and you don't have to
take it every day and so it actually
opens up some opportunities for for new
new strategies for treatment new
individuals or or some slice of the
population might be quite interested in
this so that's the implantable there's a
there was a study done actually
comparing oral now track
sonne again pavlov group did this oral
naltrexone to the implant this was the
red line is the implant the oral
naltrexone is the green line and the
purple line is the placebo arm so so
yeah if you implant a medication in
people that blocks the effects of heroin
they're going to use less heroin but
interestingly they you know it's not
like a hundred percent and there are
some variations across the the time
frame so we see significant improvements
in terms of adherence related to the
implants there's also you know this
concept of long-acting medications we're
now starting to see the early tests of
buprenorphine long-acting buprenorphine
and again these are retention rates in a
six-month the trial there were the
retention rate for the buprenorphine and
it's compared to a placebo blood by the
way placebo injection yeah it's kind of
an odd comparison since we have oral
buprenorphine but this is the way many
medications are first tested so about
twice the rate of retention with these
long-acting medications vivitrol which
is the injectable naltrexone lasts for
30 days obviously we see fifty percent
of the participants had ninety percent
of their weeks opiate free if they got
the injectable naltrexone the placebo
group had thirty five percent so people
without any active medication
thirty-five percent of them did they had
thirty five percent of the Oak of their
weeks opiate free obviously significant
differences so these long-acting
medications are interest they need to be
considered in terms of future trials and
design future trials for HIV risk
reduction they may have some significant
cost advantages although the medications
and the implants themselves are quite
expensive in terms of the staff required
in the the to deliver it that's much
less involved than a methadone treatment
program or or a regular suboxone
treatment program this is a swedish
study and I'm only mentioning it because
it's now tracks on was used to as a
treatment for amphetamine use and there
was a significant effect found in terms
of clean urine samples over the course
of of the 12 weeks these are 24 urine
samples but done over a 12-week period
so now tracks on the medication is being
used as a test is being tested as
prevention for amphetamine use that's a
significant development for HIV
prevention since right now we don't have
any effective medication assisted
treatment there are a lot of limitations
to this study the treatment studies that
we've that I've reviewed there's
measurement variability treatment
delivery variability almost all have
very short-term follow-up periods focus
has been on opiate dependent injectors
very little on stimulant abuse and no
randomized trials for treatment with HIV
or HCV endpoints
I'm going to wrap this up now and just
make a few points about the future
research and I think you've already
heard most of my conclusions throughout
the the talk here but I think it's very
important that we develop ways of
delivering treatments with lower
intensity more cost effective strategies
able to intervene with drug users before
they reach the most severe stages of
their addiction there are new strategies
being tested that are trying to identify
drug users early on and deliver
treatments before they they reach the
stage of of drug dependence and again we
need to make sure that we're considering
the the treatment costs in the cost of
delivering these various treatments
because as a public health intervention
if our if the the treatments that we're
testing the treatments that we're
developing and implementing can't be
widely disseminated or sustained there's
really not going to be a long lasting
impact on on on public health